Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Warum hat uns eigentlich noch nicht vernichtet.
Wahrscheinlich gab's Fischstäbchen oder so.
Laut Buchnetzpolitik Nummer eins sechs eins. Direkt hineingeströmt in äh eure Endgeräte noch nicht gesperrt. Noch nicht.
Finde ich, Gedelddos sind, finde ich.
Nee. Wir sind total uncool. Ist das klar?
Äh also es kann auf jeden Fall nicht daran liegen, dass die Meter eben auf besonders stabilen Beinen stehen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, daran liegt's nun wirklich nicht.
Daran liegt's nun wirklich nicht. Naja, mal gucken. Vielleicht äh können wir uns ja noch äh bisschen unbeliebt machen mit irgendwas. Aber derzeit sind ja erstmal die anderen wieder dran, sich äh um beliebt zu machen.
Oder? Womit wollen wir anfangen? Ein bisschen Feedback geben?
Weitergeht, also uns wurde ja Feedback.
Durchreichen. Wir reißen das einfach so durch. Ja.
Wir reichen das durch. Also es gab, na ja, ich habe ja sogar, also diesmal war das äh Feedback wieder ähm also gut. Also im im umfangreich, es gab sehr umfangreiches Feedback.
Umfangreich auch? Umfangreich.
Das können wir jetzt leider nicht alles. Ähm.
Nee.
Behandeln, aber es gab äh einen interessanten, wichtigen Kommentar von dieses Meta-Schreib-May.
Schreibt mir halt ähm gesagt.
Geschrieben.
Vielleicht hat er es auch, vielleicht hat sie es auch gesagt. Ähm.
Zitat, äh Sommer oder Herbst zweitausendvierzehn von Abu, einem der deutschen Extremisten, die nach Syrien ausgewandert sind und es innerhalb des IS nach sehr weit oben geschafft haben, sagte,
Das Problem ist, dass wir keine offiziellen Medien mehr haben. Twitter sperrt andauernd unsere Accounts. Wir haben versucht, auf andere soziale Netzwerke auszuweichen, aber da passiert im Grunde das Gleiche.
Die werden täglich manchmal auch stündlich gelöscht. Momentan haben wir kein Medien, über das wir ihren Besuch offiziell ankündigen können. Da ging's um eine Person,
Besuch kommt wahrscheinlich in dem Zusammenhang. Auszug aus dem Buch Jürgen Todenhöfer, Inside IS zehn Tage im Islamischen Staat,
insofern ganz interessanter Hinweis hier, dass es jetzt nicht so ist, als wäre.
Bedürfnisse einer weiteren Armada diese Sperrung durchzuführ.
Meter Schreibmail sagt dann auch gesteht ein durchaus zu, dass sie diese Accountlöschungen sicherlich auch mal um fünf Minuten beschleunigen konnten im im begründeten Einzelfällen,
Ähm,
Diese diesen Hinweis habe ich übrigens dann auch direkt äh weiter verwurstet in einem Interview. Ich würde von der Tageszeitung äh zu diesen,
Zu diesem und anderen Themen befragt und habe da direkt das das weitergereicht. Also vielen Dank. Meta schreibt mir.
Dann, ich weiß nicht, ob dann gab's ein äh äh guten Kommentar von AD. AD ist, glaube ich, sowieso wahrscheinlich,
Einer unserer häufigsten Kommentatorinnen ähm lese ich unter fast jeder Sendung immer mit guten,
Einlassungen und äh.
Hatte auch einen wichtigen äh wichtigen Hinweis, da ging's in der letzten Sendung, habe ich ja über das Tracking gesprochen und das ähm,
Facebook eben eine ähm vielleicht mehr Track oder äh die Nutzer mehr erfasst als Google und da habe ich natürlich unterschlagen, dass ähm Google ja allen möglichen.
Mist in unsere Webseiten reinbringt oder wir allen möglichen Mist von Google in unsere Webseiten einbauen da
Kommentiert ade. Facebook ist,
Facebook eine größere Ausspähe als Google zuzubilligen, ignoriert aber Google Analytics, eingebundene YouTube-Videos
Karten und Captures, Googles Werbenetzwerk und technische Dienstleistung durch Dienstleistungen, durch irgendwelche Google APIs und Fons, die ich regelmäßig in meiner Filterliste sehe,
Ich gehe davon aus, dass alle diese Kanäle für Tracking von Internetnutzern verwendet werden. Stimmt natürlich wichtiger Hinweis. Google hat ähm,
Plus eins Knopf, den sie dann mal irgendwie eine Zeit lang im Internet etablieren wollten, hat bei weitem nicht so eine Verbreitung gefunden, wie ihr
Google Analytics, wo sie also ein schönes äh von entgegen wer auf deine Seite gekommen ist, mit welchen Suchbegriffen wie lange Leute da geblieben sind. YouTube-Videos binden, alle möglichen Leute ein,
und diese Frontgeschichte ist eigentlich mit das das amüsanteste äh weil es.
Eigentlich ja sehr einfach ist, aber du musst für unterschiedliche, also bei Fonce geht's darum ähm du hast,
auf einem Browser kannst du jetzt eigentlich nur einen sehr geringen, eine sehr geringe Anzahl von erwarten,
und wenn das jetzt ein unterschiedliches Betriebssystem ist oder unterschiedlicher Browser, dann unterscheiden sich diese Fronts auch. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, eine du möchtest eine riesenlose Front haben, ja, dann wird,
in einer serifenlosen Schrift erscheinen, aber welche das ist, ist über Betriebssysteme und Browsergenerationen immer wieder unterschiedlich. Also könntest du auf die Idee kommen, einfach mal eine eigene Front zu eine spezifische Front zu benutzen und in CSS kannst du eben auch eine
vondefiniert, sagst du so, ich möchte folgenden Front Typ haben und den definiere ich jetzt und den nutze ich dann eben für folgende Elemente. Und dann,
kannst du den auch quasi auf deinem Server bereitstellen.
Macht aber keiner.
Aber das Format in indem du diese Front bereitstellen musst. Unterscheidet sich wieder über Browser und Betriebssystemvarianten,
und ebenso glaube ich auch der der Code zu der zu der Einbindung. Sodass Google eine API gemacht hat, die ähm,
Wo du quasi einen Teil von Google einblendest und Google tut nichts weiter für dich als zu erkennen, A,
das ist ein Browser, so uns wird der braucht folgenden Dateityp,
damit er diese Front machen kann und B dir halt irgendwie ein schönes Interface rauszusuchen, wo du dir das schöne von klicken kannst und dann brauchst du nur eine Zeile einzufügen und alles funktioniert.
Und das nutzen Unmengen an an Wordpress Plugins und Webseiten und so. Und da wird natürlich jedes Mal kurz bei Google Bescheid gesagt, hallo, ich bin gerade auf dieser Seite und ich brauch diesen Pfont und ich hab folgenden Browser und so, alle schon Informationen, die Google auch nutzt. Also.
Also da hängen dann halt auch teilweise Lizenz, die es mit dran, diese Web,
sind halt schon sehr praktisch auch für die Leute, dass es jetzt nicht nur pure Faulheit, sondern ähm ja, das ist halt einfach mal wieder so ein Aspekt, wo weitere Zentralinstanzen,
Sinnvoll äh erscheinen und von daher auch Verbreitung finden.
Ohne Frage tut Google da den nicht nur den Webentwicklern, sondern auch den Leuten, die sich die Seiten anschauen müssen, einen Gefallen, aber der ist eben auch nicht äh,
ohne Kosten,
dann ähm wurden wir noch gefragt äh von Ping Pong, wo denn mal warum wir denn in der letzten Sendung,
quasi im Intro über.
Die Rede von Thomas de Maizire gewitzelt haben, aber den Wortwechsel zwischen ihm und Frank Rieger auf dem IT-Gipfel nicht weiter behandelt haben. Das haben wir einfach vergessen, weil wir auch vorher schon so lange drüber äh geredet haben
ähm.
Beziehungsweise wir hatten halt auch den den O-Ton. Ich weiß nicht, hat's du? Den O-Ton schon gab's, den gab's einfach noch nicht.
Aus Erzählungen von Frank, aber es gab ihn äh noch nicht online, das Video ist jetzt online und das ging so.
Ja, ganz lustig, aber unspektakulär so äh,
Digitale Sandsäcke schleppen.
Für den Staat. Ja, na ja. Ist äh ist schon lustig, wie sie wie der Ton sich so entwickelt hat äh über die Zeit.
Steffen äh twitterte da noch Cyber-Kooperationen. Beim zweiunddreißig C3 können sich CCC-Mitglieder schnell und einfach zum freiwilligen Dienst im Bundesministerium des Inneren anmelden.
Genau, vielleicht machen wir auch noch eine Engelschicht Sandsäcke schleppen auch. Und der Datenflut hat zu werden, sollte irgendwie unsere Leitungen überspült werden,
Aber das haben wir eigentlich bisher immer ganz gut in den Griff bekommen.
Na das Ganze hat ja schon eine eine ernsthafte Komponente.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob wir jetzt eine Cyberflut haben in der ausgerechnet jetzt äh CC zehn Mitglieder, Sandsäcke schleppen müssen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob man jetzt so das Äquivalent von von Sandsäcke schleppen im im im Bereich äh der inneren Sicherheit im im oder dem allgemeinen Cyberraum hat,
Aber ist natürlich schon interessant.
Also die Frage ist, ob der de Maizire nicht inzwischen genau weiß, wie der CCC vom Organisationsgrad und von der Aufstellung her ist. Und dass diese,
Idee da eine Krisennummer zu haben. Vielleicht eher unwahrscheinlich ist.
Ich denke, das wissen die auch. Das war, glaube ich, hier auch mehr so eine.
Auch eine Botschaft. Ich will's jetzt kein Friedensangebot nennen, aber es ähm.
Ja, die haben auch Schiss voll in Ordnung ist.
Ja und also zumindest oder andersrum zu sagen, was hier echt klar draus wird, ist, die deutschen Hacker werden auf jeden Fall nicht als das Problem angesehen.
In der im digitalen Sphärenbereich.
Ah, das hört sich aber relativ bald ändern, ne? Also mit äh einer Staatstrojaner Offensive können wir äh können wir relativ bald wieder rechnen. Wir haben ja letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen. Er hat ja auch dieses äh dieses Grin.
In einem in einem politischen Diskurs. Klar, ja, aber eben nicht als,
Bedrohungsszenario oder als irgendwie Teil. Ich meine, das ist jetzt gar nicht so lange her, da da stand der CCC. Na ja okay, ist schon schon ein bisschen länger her, aber zu Beginn ja, war's ja eher so, dass,
dass der Club sehr wohl aufpassen musste, äh nicht selbst, äh unter die Gesetzgebung terroristische Vereinigung zu fallen,
bewegt und die Aufgeregtheiten rund um,
NASA, Heck und andere Skandale mit der achtziger Jahre,
Das war schon noch ein ganz anderer, ganz andere Stimmung, die eben auch sehr davon geprägt war, wie wenig man eigentlich sich kannte und verstand.
Und äh oder die gegenseitigen äh äh Motive auch nicht anerkannt hat.
Das ist schon anders und das hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass Leute, die eigentlich auch so in unserem Kulturkreis,
groß geworden sind oder die zumindest mit der Präsenz unseres Kulturkreises groß geworden sind,
Die sitzen jetzt in diesem Organisation.
Frage ist, ob ob der CCC jetzt tief gefallen oder hochgeklettert ist, da scheinen sich ja jetzt die Geister.
Scheinen sie ja jetzt die Geister. Ich sage mal, ganz positiv. Wir wollten ja eigentlich schon immer ernst genommen werden und das äh findet statt.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es auch wirklich nicht ähm also ich meine, keine Situation, äh keine,
Organisation wird es ablehnen. Ähm.
Wenn ihr an Einflussmöglichkeiten gegeben werden oder angeboten werden insbesondere von im politischen Bereich, wo der CCC ja seine seinen Einfluss auch durchaus geltend macht immer wer.
Ja, da gibt's Grenzen so, aber ich denke, die sind auch bekannt und die werden auch äh beachtet und von daher,
obliegt man ja dann sozusagen auch gleichzeitig an der öffentlichen Beobachtung und auch einer Beobachtung durch die die Szene von innen und bisher denke ich mal, bewegt sich da nichts im kritischen Bereich, zumindest meine Meinung.
Atem, weißt du, wir hatten ja jetzt ähm also vervollständige diese Liste. Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ja, Netzneutralität.
Was fehlt?
Netzsperren. Das hatte noch gefehlt in diesem Jahr.
Denkt, es ist alles, ne? Man denkt, man hat's alles zusammen, ja? Nee, kommt noch einer. Kommt noch einer weit gefehlt. Ich habe bei der äh hör mir auf, ja, dass der Bundesgerichtshof hat jetzt ähm,
Zwei Urteile äh erklingen lassen äh zum Thema Netzsperren und zwar ging's ja um zwei Verfahren oder ein ein Urteil, zwei Verfahren. Da ging's um einmal die,
ein Verband der Tonträgerhersteller, der eine Seite namens Goldesel oder ja Goldesel äh gesperrt haben wollte.
Und einmal um die GEMA, die hätten wir auch lange nicht mehr, die eine Seite namens 3DL Punkt AM gesperrt haben wollte,
und ähm behandle das jetzt mal am, an dem Fall der der GEMA. Die GEMA hatte also gegen die Deutsche Telekom geklagt,
und hat gesagt, ähm wir wollen, dass ihr diese Internetseite sperrt, weil dort eine Sammlung urheberrechtlich geschützter Musik bereitgestellt wird. Hm?
Ja.
Und dann rate geh mal argumentiert, wir sind ja hier dafür da, die,
Rechte, die die Rechte unserer Mitglieder,
auf Max, auf maximale auszureizen und äh deshalb müssen wir auch gegen äh Urheberrechtsverletzer selbst vorgehen,
Ja, ist aber,
wegen dieser ganzen internationalen Geschichte unmöglich. Die Domains sind teilweise irgendwo in Ländern äh registriert, wo wir keine Juristics haben oder wo wir keine Regierung geltend machen können, teilweise anonymisiert, wir kriegen's nicht hin.
Und deshalb äh ist die einzige Möglichkeit, die Tür zuzumauern, also die Seite sperren zu lassen,
und genau dieses Sperren sei den Excess Providern zumutbar und technisch möglich. Hier ist wichtig zu unterscheiden, man redet einmal von den,
Content Providern, dass es in diesem Fall diese Seite 3DL Punkt AM und dem,
Provider, das ist in diesem Fall die Telekom und weil man den Content Provider nicht irgendwie dazu bewegt,
Hat seine Seite zuzumachen oder überhaupt herauszufinden, wie man ihn kontaktieren kann. Ähm wendet man sich jetzt an die Telekom.
Bekanntlich die letzte Meile kontrolliert zwischen den zahlenden Nutzern und dem großen weiten Internet.
Zumindest in Teilen, weil nun ist ja auch nur für einen Teil der Benutzer.
Genau, als Access Provider, die sich für die Telekom entschieden haben, ja?
Und die Deutsche Telekom hat gesagt, na ja, also Freunde, erstens, diese ganzen Sperrmaßnahmen, das hat man doch alles schon, die Debatte lassen sich umgehen. Wir können keine einrichten, die absolut wirksam ist.
Wir sehen das Problem des Overblocking, wenn wir einmal mit diesem Mist anfangen, das heißt am Ende werden mehr Seiten gesperrt als ähm sinnvoll ist, das heißt äh wir tun da anderen,
Content, Anbietern Unrecht und machen unsere Kunden traurig,
und weiterhin äh ist das Sperren von solchen von Internetinhalten ein Grundrechtseinschnitt und dafür ist ja wohl ein Gesetz notwendig, denn
die Einschränkung von Grundrechen kann man ja nicht irgendwie aufgrund eines äh eines Briefes der GEMA machen.
Und verweist dann darauf, ja, also der die Maßgabe löschen statt sperren,
ja, mit der haben wir auch bei richtiger Kriminalität, ja, also nicht bei irgendwelchen Fallgeschichten da, sondern bei richtiger Kriminalität. In den letzten Jahren sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht und wir würden euch bitten,
euch doch äh daran zu halten und zu orientieren. Das war so die Argumentation, die von beiden Seiten vorgetragen wurden,
So und jetzt sagt der BGH, na wir schauen mal hier ins Telemediengesetz. Da gibt es ähm,
Nach Paragraph sieben erstmal nur eine allgemeine Haftung für eigene und zu eigen gemachte Inhalte,
und nach Paragraph acht keine Haftung für fremde Informationen. Ja, also ist nicht verantwortlich für für fremde Informationen.
Und du musst auch nicht.
Ähm nach Paragraph sieben, die übermittelten oder gespeicherten Daten ständig auf Rechtsverstöße Verstöße überprüfen,
Ja, also du eine Kontrolle ist dir da nicht da bist du von freigestellt, ne? Das kennen wir immer diese Haftungsprivilegien, von denen wir an anderer Stelle auch oft sprechen.
Allerdings, wenn es Verpflichtungen zur Entfernung oder Sperrung der Nutzung gibt.
Aufgrund von anderen allgemeinen Gesetzen.
Dann gilt da diese nicht Verantwortlichkeit nicht und das heißt im Klartext üblicherweise, ich hatte das Beispiel schon öfter genannt, ähm.
Jemand schreibt einen äh wirren Kommentar auf,
Logbuch Netzwerk DE. Dieser Kommentar wird automatisch ins Internet geschaltet. In dem Moment, wo wir Kenntnis davon erlangen, dass dieser äh rechtswidrig ist, müssen wir ihn löschen, vorher nicht. Ja, also das ist quasi die äh Waage, die da äh,
gefunden wurde. So, jetzt hatte,
der europäische Gerichtshof ins Jahr zweitausendvierzehn, Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete, entschieden, dass Websperren durch Internetanbieter generell erlaubt sein können,
solange sie verhältnismäßig und zumutbar bleiben. Und das müssen aber, müssten aber nationale äh Gerichte,
leisten, einerseits den Schutz der Urheberrechte und andererseits äh die wirtschaftliche Freiheit der Internetanbieter und die Informationsfreiheit der Nutzer gegeneinander abzuwägen.
Und das hat jetzt hier der BGH in dem Bereich getan, dass er nämlich sagt, na ja okay, also,
Unterstrengen Voraussetzungen sind Netzsperren zulässig. Aber.
Nicht generell. Du musst als allererstes dich bei dem,
Content Provider melden, der wird im Zweifelsfall sagen, also Content Provider ist derjenige, der die Inhalte dort tatsächlich,
anstellt, der wird im Zweifelsfall sagen, leck mich am Arsch, sonst hätte er es ja nicht von vorne reingemacht. Dann wendest du dich natürlich an den Horst Provider und sagst,
hier du auf deinen Servern, ne, hältst dich da eine Seite auf, du machst die zugänglich.
Also nicht auf deinen Zoo, also der Content-Provider ist sozusagen der Owner des Servers, der Hosting Provider ist derjenige, der das Teil im Reck stehen hat
und äh der Excess-Provider ist derjenige, der den Weg zu diesen Hosting Provider eben Pfeil bietet und ja, der Hosting Provider könnte in Kabel ziehen, er konnte einen Provider könnte löschen. Ähm ja
und wenn das.
Wenn du das alles durch bist, wenn das alles durch hast, ähm.
Und sogar sagt der BGH hier, du kannst ins obliegt dir in Zumutbarem Umfang selbst Nachforschung anzustellen, wer dahinter stecken könnte, könnte es zum Beispiel eine Detailbeauftragen.
Um oder ein auf solche Ermittlungen spezialisiertes Unternehmen einschalten. Die staatlichen Ermittlungsbehörden ins Boot holen und so weiter,
Also, wenn, indem du eine Anzeige erstattest, wenn das alles nicht hilft, dann kannst du äh einen Netzsperre äh verlangen.
Ja, schön.
Geil. Dann haben wir jetzt demnächst die GEMA hier rumrennen und dann sperren die irgendwie das ganze Netz, ne? Und der, also was ich grade nur am Rande benannt habe, das mit dem,
ähm mit dem Overblocking ist natürlich so der Hausprovider, der hat unter Umständen unter einer IP.
Durchaus mehrere Sachen liegen. Und wenn ihr jetzt oft anhand der IP sperrst, dann hast du mitunter relativ hohen Kollateralschaden. Nämlich alles, was da mit drauf liegt. Also wenn man irgendwie,
Linus äh Minus Neumann DE sperrt das Licht auf so einem auf so einem Webspace,
da sperrst du aber ein paar hundert Leute mit, ich hab mich mal ein bisschen auf dem Server umgeschaut, da sind.
Unter der selben IP-Adresse.
Unter derselben IP-Adresse sind sehr viele, ja.
Okay? Ja, also ich meine, ähm.
So ganz äh unüberraschend,
Ganz überraschend sollte es jetzt äh auch nicht äh kommen, weil der BGH sich hier auch wiederum auf ein Urteil des EUGH äh bezieht aus dem letzten Jahr, von dem ich ehrlich gesagt nicht weiß,
Wir das eigentlich besprochen haben, vermutlich, ne? Genau, wo im Prinzip der EUGH äh auch festgestellt hat, dass Websperren durch Internetanbieter erlaubt sein können.
So lange sie verhältnismäßig und zumutbar sind. Äh das spielt ja hier in der Aussage vom Bundesgerichtshof auch eine,
Rolle, ich meine, um vielleicht jetzt mal die nicht ganz so schlimmen Aspekte dieser Meldung nochmal zu beleuchten. Einerseits ist hier eben von ähm,
Hosts die Rede, die jetzt nicht nur ausschließlich rechtsverletzende Inhalte haben, sondern eben auch äh wo auch ein paar rechtmäßige dabei sein können so, wo wo die aber nicht ins Gewicht fallen,
Da mag die Abwägung jetzt für Sachen sein, wo ein rechtswidriger Inhalt sozusagen die Ausnahme ist, nochmal äh anders ausfallen, auch wenn das etwas schwammig äh ist, zumindest in der aktuellen Informationslage hier,
Sie betonen halt, dass eben die Websperren nur das letzte Mittel seien. Und in dem Moment, wo halt äh die Detailbeauftragung zur Ermittlung von Content-Anbietern et cetera alles nochmal als viables äh Mittel genannt wird und das findet ja hier statt.
Würde ich sagen, dass zumindest so eine massenhafte automatisierte äh äh Sperrung an dieser Stelle schwierig werden dürfte.
Sagte ich unmöglich, aber schwierig.
Ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz, das Urteil ist jetzt noch nicht veröffentlicht, es gibt lediglich eine Pressemitteilung zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt des Bundesgerichtshofs. Die GEMA hat sich da noch nicht zu geäußert, aber ich kann mir in etwa vorstellen, wie die Pressemitteilung dann aussieht, wenn sie draußen ist.
Ne, obwohl ja im Prinzip ihre Klage erst mal in der Form abgewiesen wurde rein technisch, aber das wird dann schon äh entsprechend um umgejubelt werden, um da äh eine andere Sicht drauf zu eröffnen,
Ja, na ja gut, ich meine, dann haben wir ja zumindest alles komplett jetzt.
Genau, die Sendung zu dem EUGH-Urteil ist Lokbuchnetzpolitik siebenundneunzig, garantiert nippelfrei.
Sehr schön.
Wir bleiben bei den äh Telemedien und Telekommunikationsdiensten.
Und da gibt es seit langer Zeit eine Debatte, um Kugels Gmail. Ähm.
Ein Telekommunikationsdienst unterliegt sehr ausführlicher Regulation,
in Deutschland. Ein Telemediendienst nach Telemedien,
Gesetz durchaus weniger Regulation. Und es gibt,
Seit langer Zeit von der Deutschen Telekom zum Beispiel die Forderung, so etwas wie WhatsApp,
ähm nicht mehr als Telemediendienst zu behandeln, sondern bitteschön als Telekommunikationsdienst.
Die Deutsche Telekom mit ihrem SMS oder MMS eben wirklich völlig haarsträubenden Anforderungen unterliegt,
im Bereich Datenschutz, Überwachungsschnittstelle und ähnlichen Dingen,
Die Deutsche Telekom fordert also für Telekommunikationsdienste seit langem, äh für Telemediendienste, die Kommunikationsdienstleistungen bieten, seit langem,
Ähnliche Regulation, ja, so ein bisschen Stockholm-Syndrom. Statt zu sagen, okay, lockert mal diese ganzen Regulationen beim Telekom, bei der Telekommunikation, sagen sie halt, okay, jetzt wollen wir aber auch, dass alle hier reingeritten werden. Äh wir hatten das,
oder ich hatte das auch schon mal im Rahmen des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes behandelt, wo eben auch.
Teilweise Anpassungen stattgefunden hatten. Jetzt gibt es also in gleicher in gleichem Themenbereich.
Einen seit zweitausendzwölf andauernden Streit zwischen der Bundesnetzagentur und dem Internetkonzern Google,
denn zweitausendzwölf schrieb die ähm die Bundesnetzagentur Google zum ersten Mal. Moin, ähm hier ist eine Formular, meldet mal bitte euer.
Euer komisches Gmail als Telekommunikationsdienst an, sonst ähm wird teuer, weil dann betreibt ihr hier einen Telekommunikationsdienst, der nicht entsprechend vernünftig ja und das okay wir dann da hin,
Google hat gesagt, ja, nee, äh gib das mal in, gib das mal den Anwälten. Die klagen dagegen.
Und Google sagt, na ja, wir kontrollieren ja diese Signalübertragung über das Internet nicht,
Und das wäre äh eine Voraussetzung für den Betrieb eines Telekommunikationsdienstes und sagt deshalb, das was wir hier haben, mit Gmail ist, wenn überhaupt ein Telemediendienst,
und jetzt gab es also einen Gerichtsbeschluss, der sagt, nö.
Du musst Google Mögle G-Mail jetzt bitte als Telekommunikationsdienst anmelden und dann eben sich auch den ganzen daraus entstehenden Anforderungen in Datenschutz und Überwachung ähm beugen.
Ja, interessant.
Ja, ist wirklich sehr interessant, ist auf auf mehreren äh Ebenen finde ich das interessant. Vor allem finde ich es interessant, weil das natürlich auch eine eine Entwicklung, eine technische Entwicklung im Internet auf einmal widerspiegelt, die äh einfach die Sichtweisen mal wieder komplett,
verschiebt. Bisher hatte man halt immer den Betreiber der großen Kommunikationsnetze, der eben auch,
Die Kerndienste,
quasi mitliefert und die so gar nicht getrennt waren. Man hat ja nicht zwischen dem Telefonieren und dem Bereitstellen der Leitung für das Telefonieren,
und SMS ist auch so ein Dienst, der dann dazugekommen ist, der dann ja auch integraler Bestandteil war und weil ja,
Ein Telekommunikationskonzern wie die Telekom so ein Infrastrukturanbieter und Vernetzer. Das betreibt war das ja sozusagen. Selbstverständlich gehört das dann immer noch in die selbe Regelungsdomäne. Jetzt,
haben wir einfach durch das Internet eine deutlich stärkere Trennung zwischen,
Datenweiterleitung auf der einen Seite und Anwendungen, die da drauf gefahren werden und auf einmal sind aber diese Anwendungen in der Lage.
Im selben Maße, wenn nicht sogar noch viel mehr Tele, tja Dienstleistung sage ich jetzt mal, äh darüber zu realisieren.
Viel mehr Tele.
Viel mehr Tele. Richtig, richtig, richtig viele Tele. Äh,
Ich meine, die Zahlen, WhatsApp wurde jetzt genannt, äh keine Ahnung, wo die jetzt grade gelandet sind, aber wir reden ja hier wirklich von ähm Millionen,
Abermillionen von von gleichzeitigen äh Usern und das eben dann auch nochmal weltweit. Also ein ganz anderes Profil, aber letzten Endes tun sie natürlich was äh
ähnliches und jetzt ist halt die denke, naja gut, dann müssen wir das mal jetzt genau so regeln,
wie äh wäre das mit der Telekom auch gemacht haben, muss man sich halt einfach jetzt fragen, warum ist die Telekom so geregelt? Ist sie so geregelt, weil sie Telefonie geboten hat oder weil sie die Kabel für die Telefonie geboten hat?
Das hier ist ausgerechnet Gmail hier im Fokus steht. Das wiederum verstört mich sehr, weil das nun.
Sehr viel mehr ein Dienst ist, der ja auch nicht in sich geschlossen ist. Also WhatsApp ist ein besseres Beispiel,
spielt sich halt alles nur innerhalb von WhatsApp ab und äh hat also wenig bis,
kaum irgendwelche externen Abhängigkeiten und Auswirkungen. Aber gerade Gmail steht ja sozusagen mitten in einem vergleichsweise offen definierten Kommunikationsfeld,
und äh,
dass jetzt also der Streit sich ausgerechnet darüber entfacht und man nicht ganz andere Sachen aus der Schublade rauszieht bei Google, äh das das finde ich schon irgendwie,
Merkwürdig.
Google hat ja auch Infrastruktur, so ist es ja nicht, ist ja nicht so, dass sie gar keine Signalwege äh kontrollieren würden, sie haben natürlich deutlich mehr Signalwege als viele andere Anbieter
Also WhatsApp betreibt keine Glasfasern in äh Deutschland, Google sehr wohl
nur es endet halt einfach irgendwo und letztlich ist es die ganze Föderation dieser ganzen Signalwege, die das Netz ausmacht.
Knifflig.
Ja, also dieses das Telemediendienst, äh Telekommunikationsdienste inzwischen überholt haben oder überholen. Ähm führt ja zu allerlei anderen Phänomenen.
Ne, nicht zuletzt.
Nicht zuletzt zu diesem gesamten Debatten um Netzneutralität und was wir da nicht alles ähm haben. Weil da äh sich gegenseitig das Schwarze unterm Fingernagel nicht gegönnt wird. Ähm.
Gmail als Telekommunikationsdienst? Naja, wird spannend.
Ja, also die Forderungen, die jetzt im Raum steht, ist die sollen da befolgen, aber es gab jetzt keine Entscheidung, oder?
Doch doch, das ist äh das ist eine äh ein Urteil des Verwaltungsgerichts Köln, wenn ich mich nicht täusche? Ähm liegt der mal ganz schnell?
Verwaltungsgericht Köln. Müssen sie jetzt machen.
Aber das ist doch sicherlich, da kann man da sicherlich nochmal gegen vorgehen, ohne das hat jetzt noch keine unmittelbare Bindung, oder?
Das wird Google sicherlich äh sich nicht gefallen lassen, aber wir werden's sehen. Also ähm,
Ne, die Entscheidung ist jetzt irgendwie erst ähm am Mittwoch, den vierundzwanzigsten, äh den fünfundzwanzigsten November bekannt geworden. Ähm.
Das Urteil schon am elften November äh getroffen worden und äh man kann
einlegen, beim Oberverwaltungsgericht in Münster und ich gehe davon aus, dass Google gerade äh auf Google Maps schon guckt, wo Münster überhaupt ist.
Ja, bleiben wir in der in der lustigen Welt der Gerichte und Urteile und äh putzigen Klagen. Demnächst gibt's eine mehr,
Äh wir haben ja schon berichtet über den Fall, ähm der Auseinandersetzung zwischen Bild,
und den AdBlock Plus äh Betreiber Ayo äh wo dann quasi als Kollateralschaden auch der,
YouTuber Tobias Richter auch gleich noch eine Abmahnung ins Haus bekommen hat, weil er ja es gewagt hat, ein Video ins Internet zu stellen, in dem er,
per Screencasting erläutert, wie man sein AdBlock Plus denn so konfigurieren kann, dass die
neuerlich eingeführte Sperre des AdBlockers auf Bild DE auch umgangen werden kann.
Und das äh fand halt der Springer Verlag überhaupt nicht lustig, das äh äh Leute einfach ihr Wissen teilen,
Und ähm wir haben ja schon zur,
mit Beruhigung zur Kenntnis genommen, dass der äh Betreffende Youtuber sich hier nicht äh so ohne weiteres ähm verarschen lässt und erstmal überhaupt keine Unterlassungserklärung unterzeichnet hat,
auf Anraten seiner Anwälte, da ist er wohl ganz gut beraten und geht jetzt auch in die Offensive,
denn er möchte nun gar nicht erst abwarten wie das vielleicht ausgehen kann oder auch nicht, kann ja auch sein, dass Springer das wieder zurückzieht und dass das alles so ein bisschen im Raum stehen bleibt. Da geht sozusagen in die Offensive und,
holt das Instrument einer negativen Feststellungsklage aus der Schublade hervor.
Das hatten wir hier schon mal geschildert, da ging's um die Freifunkgeschichte und ähm,
der Begriff ist nach wie vor sehr äh sehr verwirrend oder sehr also warum ist das nicht vielleicht auch eine positive Klage? Es ist im Prinzip so, wenn du eine Abmahnung bekommst,
dann ist das ja quasi eine Androhung. Sagt, wenn du das nicht tust, dann geht's aber rund. Dann dann schreiben wir dir eine Rechnung.
Genau, solange die nicht zurückgezogen ist, bleibt das einfach im Raum.
Ja, aber wenn du dann einfach dieser an dieser ähm Abmahnung nicht Folge leistest, so wie das der Tobias Richter ja hier getan hat,
und der andere, derjenige, der dich abgemahnt hat, äh zieht nicht, ja, also macht nicht weiter, dann bleibt das halt,
im Raum hängen. Ja, das heißt, der äh es gibt dann keine das ist dann ein nicht definierter rechtlicher Zustand, der dann erreicht wird.
Und der Tobias Richter hat offenbar.
Begründeten äh eine begründete Annahme, dass Springer genau das tut, denn nachdem er ihnen gesagt hat, ähm ich lasse mir von euch das nicht verbieten.
Dann seitdem hat er nichts mehr von Springer gehört. So und wenn Springer jetzt einfach sagt, aha, Mist, der wehrt sich, lass mal liegen, dann,
War das eben so, aber damit hat sich an der Rechtssituation, an der.
Sage ich mal, der äh klar an der rechtlichen Klarheit nichts geändert. Deswegen geht er jetzt hin und sagt, okay,
Klage jetzt gegen den Verlag und lasse dem Verlag die Behauptung untersagen,
dass ich mit Hilfe meiner Videoanleitung eine technische Schutzmaßnahme vor urheberrechtlich geschützte Inhalte umgangen hätte.
Damit lässt er sich quasi, will er quasi ein Urteil forcieren, dass das Gericht sagt.
Die Basis der Abmahnungen, die Springer dort versendet hat, ist nicht gegeben,
Und dann können die nämlich keine weiteren mehr schicken, weil dann gibt's ein Urteil, dass du keine Rechtsgrundlage für diese Abmahnung hast. Und das war auch genau der gleiche Fall bei diesen Freifunnkgeschichten, wo
Freifunnkar hingegangen sind und gesagt haben, nix hier, nix. Wir sagen, sind frei Funker und ihr lasst die Abmahnungen äh einfach.
Also ging's um Störerhaftung, ne?
Genau, da ging's um Störerhaftung. Da haben die da, da wurden sie auch quasi abgemahnt, haben gesagt, wir sind Freifunker, dann haben die,
abmahnen Kanzleien in der Regel gesagt, na OK alles klar da gehen wir nicht weiter hinterher und dann haben die Freifunnker irgendwann gesagt so nee nee,
Freunde, so jetzt geht's rund. So, jetzt wollen wir hier mal Klarheit haben, damit ihr endlich aufhört, diese dämlichen Abmahnungen zu verschicken. Und das möchte der Tobias Richter jetzt machen,
und hat ähm.
Dazu um Spenden gebeten, weil er natürlich das äh Prozessrisi Prozesskostenrisiko trägt. Ähm,
zu gewinnen gibt es das ähm Springer eben vor Gericht äh klar erklärt kriegt, so nicht, meine Freunde.
Ähm und dann natürlich auch ein schönes Video wo ähm,
wo er diese Anleitung, also dann stellt er diese Anleitung wieder online. Die hat er ja offline genommen,
Und man kriegt dann auch sein Geld zurück. Ja, zu verlieren gibt es das Geld und dann hat man's versucht. Aber dieser Deal ist schon vorbei, weil die Crowdfunding-Kampagne ist schon erfolgreich, ist schon überfinanziert. Ähm.
Innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden war die Kohle zusammen. Es ging hier um siebentausend äh Euro knapp.
R5 hat er nur gesammelt, wahrscheinlich hat er.
Nein, nein, er hat fünftausend über die Spenden äh Seite und dann nochmal zweitausend bei PayPal, also das kam sozusagen alles schon zusammen und da hat er jetzt auch gesagt, okay, mehr äh brauche ich jetzt auch gar nicht.
Ja, also ich denke, das hat eine eine gute Chance erfolgreich für ihn auszugehen,
Soweit meine äh uninformierte, juristisch nicht fundierte Meinung dazu. Wir werden das beobachten und.
Mal gucken, was sich daraus ergibt, weil das wäre ja auch insofern sehr interessant, als dass wir ja ohnehin dieser ganzen Debatte mit äh also in diesem eigentlichen Konflikt mit Eyo und Springer schon diese Behauptung der,
technischen Schutzvorrichtungen. Das ist ja sozusagen auch an an der Stelle schon, also der Vorwurf gegenüber dem AdBlocker als solcher, das steht ja schon auf dünnen Eis.
Genau und da soll ja auch jetzt mal an dem Eis mal ein bisschen rumgehämmert werden.
Genau, wenn jetzt zumindest schon mal klar wäre, dass ein Video da drüber, wie man das dann wiederum nochmal aktivieren kann, wenn das schon mal nicht reinfällt, dann wäre schon mal ein erster Schritt äh getan, auch wenn es eigentlich erstmal nichts damit zu tun hat. Ich persönlich denke ähm,
sich hier ein bisschen überdreht hat und sicherlich äh,
nicht als Sieger aus diesem Ring hervorgehen kann, aber was weiß ich schon.
Ah ja, was haben wir?
Was haben wir nicht schon alles gesehen?
Ja. Hi Leute. Leute schon gesehen, unglaublich. Sieht man auch jeden Tag wieder neu davon.
Verlassen wir die Gerichte, betreten wir das Parlament.
NSA. Untersuchungsausschuss, der sogenannte hat wieder getagt.
Kinder. Ja, wir also ich,
Die tagen ja inzwischen nicht mehr, die zanken ja nur noch. Ähm wir wir also wir erinnern uns, es gibt die von äh die ausgesiebten NSA Selektoren, also die Selektoren, die die NSA den BND gegeben hat, die hat der Graulich,
geprüft und die Opposition und niemand anderes darf sie sehen.
Und deshalb hat die Opposition eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt, weil sie diese ähm,
ähm Selektoren der NSA auch selber einsehen möchte. So viel die Vergangenheit. Dann hatte das ähm
PKGR, das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, BND Selektoren gesehen. Darüber hatten wir in der letzten Woche gesprochen und es verhärtete sich der es erhärtete sich der Verdacht, dass doch,
ähm der BND gegen deutsche und europäische Ziele spioniert hat,
Das waren diese, ich weiß nicht, neunhundert Seiten oder was wir da irgendwie äh unglaublich, ja? Und jetzt.
Haben die Obleute des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses am Montag,
Gelegenheit gehabt, eine Liste mit zehntausend bis zwanzigtausend solcher kritischer BND Selektoren im Kanzleramt einzusehen unter hohen Sicherheits- und Geheimhaltungsanforderungen, das auch das hatten wir in den letzten äh Sendungen,
angekündigt, dass das geschehen würde. Und es ist natürlich, ne, das Masthema morgens mit einem Coffee to go in der Hand,
kurz rüber ins Kanzleramt, lies dir kurz äh fünfzehn äh zwanzigtausend Selektoren durch und dann ist ja auch dem der Kontrolle und der Aufsicht Genüge getan, ne?
Man darf sich sogar Notizen machen. Man darf die Notizen bloß nicht aus diesem Raum heraustragen.
Genau. Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Indem die ganzen Unterlagen liegen.
Aber sonst ist da völlige Transparenz, völlige Transparenz.
Sind übrigens auch nur die Ob-Leute, also noch nicht mal alle Mitglieder.
So und jetzt sagt die Opposition unser schöner erster Untersuchungsausschuss,
NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, wie er landläufig genannt wird. Der soll auch diese Selektoren des BND genau unter die Lupe nehmen.
Und die Bundesregierung sagt, nö, wieso,
die sind doch überhaupt nicht Teil des Untersuchungsgegenstands und deshalb sind sie allein ist sie ein sich allein, dem parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium äh,
gegeben und dass wir euch da mal irgendwie, ne, Vormittag haben, reinblicken lassen, das ist doch schon da sind wir jetzt ja wirklich am Maximum der, der, der Rechtsbeigerei, dass wir euch überhaupt so weit entgegenkommen, ja?
Und ähm entsprechend der Bundesregierung natürlich auch dann die Meinung der ähm Koalitionsparteien im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss.
Und dann sagt die äh, ob Frau der Linken, Martina Renner, ja, also eine, die auch am Montag dann dort wann sich das angeschaut hat, ähm nach dieser,
nachdem sie am Montag da war, sagt sie dann, am am Mittwoch,
Es gibt einen klaren Bezug zwischen dem BND Suchmerkmalen und den der NSA, teils sind die sogar identisch. Insgesamt sehr stark miteinander verzahnt. Hier geht es um den Kern des Skandals,
nämlich vor allem das, was Konstantin Notz dann auch äh betont hat, um da die Frage des Ringtausches, nämlich die Zusammenarbeit.
Also entweder wird jetzt der Untersuchungsauftrag erweitert des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses.
Damit diese Vektoren explizit sozusagen Teil dieses Auftrages werden und damit im Prinzip ja auch der BND sozusagen auch in den Mittelpunkt kommt.
Oder,
Sagen, sagt die Opposition. Dann machen wir einen neuen machen wir noch einen Untersuchungsausschuss, der dann eben diesen Untersuchungsauftrag bekommt. Ähm sie werden also.
Ein Antrag für die nächste Plenarsitzung im Bundestag stellen um offiziell den Untersuchungsgegenstand des ersten Untersuchungsausschusses zu erweitern auf die BND Selektoren,
Ähm das werden sie aber im Zweifelsfall nicht hinkriegen, weil die Koalition dann sagt so.
Das wollen wir aber jetzt nicht.
Nö, das wollen wir nicht und wir haben hier weiß ich nicht wie viel Prozent nochmal. Das ist so eine hohe Zahl, dass ich sie immer bis dahin kann ich gar nicht zählen. Über siebzig Prozent oder so, ne.
Und wenn die Opposition, wenn die Koalition das dann gesagt hat, dann werden Grüne und Linke einen eigenen Untersuchungsausschuss für BND Selektoren beantragen.
Und den können dann Union und SPD nicht verhindern, weil äh es ja die Minderheitsrechte der Opposition gibt, die an dieser Stelle sicherstellen, dass diese kleine Minderheit auch einen Untersuchungsausschuss berufen kann,
Tja.
Interessant eher diese diese Minderheits äh äh Geschichte, die ist mir neu gewesen. Also ich weiß, weiß gar nicht, wie wie dieser Mechanismus äh.
Wurde angepasst, wenn ich mich recht entsinne,
Es war so, dass sie zu sogar noch zu wenig waren, um überhaupt in die Minderheitsrechte zu Fall, äh die die überhaupt zu bekommen, weil sie noch da runter sind. Und das wurde dann irgendwie äh gnädigerweise angepasst.
Okay, also einfach diese angepasste Regelung, nachdem die ähm Koalitionsmehrheit so so erdrückend.
Wenn ich das.
Fünfundzwanzig Prozent.
Genau, das war damals eine Debatte. Ich würde davon ausgehen, es kann aber auch sein, dass die dass die Grenze für das Berufen eines anderen Untersuchungsausschusses äh eines Untersuchungsausschusses ohnehin so gering ist.
So, dann hatten wir am Mittwoch eine Sitzung.
Also ich glaube, die alte Grenze lag bei fünfundzwanzig Prozent. Wir haben aber derzeit neunundsiebzig Prozent Koalition.
Und jetzt ist es, ich weiß nicht, also wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt einfach auf zwanzig Prozent gesetzt worden.
Ja, aber soll man noch ein bisschen noch mehr spekulieren oder sollen wir einfach sagen, okay, wir wissen es nicht. Nein, wirklich, ich.
Ich versuche mich gerade zu erinnern, wie die Regelung war.
Ich glaube, achtzehn Prozent.
Achtzehn meinst du.
Achtzehn Prozent, das.
Das ist doch jetzt du bist du bist doch romantisch jetzt hier.
Das wäre einfach mal witzig gewesen, wenn sie gesagt hätten, ja FDP Klaus.
Die FDP-Klausel sozusagen.
Also wir sehen.
Die kommen auch noch wieder, ich sag's dir.
Na also,
Wir müssen irgendwann auch mal so eine Klatsch äh Sparte hier machen, weil das hier jetzt diese beiden Piraten äh von der von der von der Piratenpartei zur FDP gegangen sind,
Ich meine, das kannst du ja als seriöses äh Nachrichtenmedium, wie wir es sind.
Ehemalige Vorsitzende.
Schlömmer und.
Ähm März.
Ja, sind jetzt bei der FDP. Meine Gitte.
Du, also.
Ich kann das ja nicht mal sagen, ich meine, wenn ich.
Äh immer schauen, wie der Wind weht so.
Man muss auch immer schauen, wo, also.
Jetzt mal, klar, dat lacht man sich natürlich äh scheckig drüber. Deswegen machen wir es auch nicht in dieser Sendung, weil wir sind ja, wir wir können ja nicht hier unseren wir haben uns unseren Ruf mühsig erarbeitet.
Genau, Mensch und Klatschpalte dann zumindest eine eigene Kapitelmarke. Jetzt bleiben wir dann doch erst mal bei unserem Untersuchungsausschuss. Also müssen wir
kurz zusammenzufassen, Selektoreneinsicht nur für ob Leute nur unter Kontrolle kontrollierten Bedingungen, Opposition ist immer noch ja
schlecht gelaunt und droht jetzt sozusagen mit einem zweiten Untersuchungsausschuss und da äh,
äh kriegt auch die Koalition schon so ein bisschen äh Schnappatmung und das könne man ja nicht machen und überhaupt und das haben wir uns hier so eingelesen und irgendwie unser schöner Untersuchungsausschuss und bäh.
Also scheint mir jetzt ein ganz interessantes äh schwer zu sein, was sie da aus der Scheide gezogen haben. Mal gucken, ob sie sich auch trauen zuzuschlagen.
Da habe ich keinen Zweifel, also was äh Konstantin von Notz und Martina Renner, wie die dadrauf die da insbesondere die beiden diesen äh in diesen Untersuchungsausschuss treiben,
Das ist schon äh enorm und äh.
Gehört sehr entschlossen.
Ja, ja. Die ist, aber sei nicht zu Spaß.
So, also kommen wir denn jetzt auch wirklich mal zum NSA Untersuchungsausschuss? Da gab's jetzt äh gestern zwei Gäste.
Ähm einmal den Alois Nölbauer, das ist der Chef der BND-Außenstelle in Gablingen und der war äh gar nicht so,
gar nicht so gesprächig. Der ließ sich im Prinzip.
News.
Ließ sich gar nichts aus der Nase ziehen. Ähm und es kam dann also während der äh Vernehmung immer wieder zur heftigen verbalen äh,
stark abtauschen zwischen ihm und den Abgeordneten, in dem Fall natürlich den Abgeordneten, hauptsächlich der Opposition, aber nicht nur, denn.
Wann immer Nöpower sagt, beantragt hat, dass die an dass sie ihm gestellten Fragen zurückgewiesen sollen werden,
ungerecht behandelt würde, hat der Vorsitzende von der CDU.
Dem nicht stattgegeben. Also da hat er auch durchaus äh mitgegrillt, der Patrick. Ähm,
nach langer, längerem Hin und Her hat er dann so einige wenige Sachen gesagt, also ja, hauptsächlich betreibe man da in Gablingen kurz Wellenerfassung.
Und bei dieser Kurzwellenkommunikation äh würde man ja jetzt nicht irgendwie Individualkommunikation wie Telekom, äh wie Telefonie oder E-Mail äh durchführen,
ähm sondern eher so militärischer Funk oder sowas und äh.
Da wer also sehr sich jetzt irgendwie nicht so im im Problem, aber er könnte damit natürlich mit dieser Kurzwellenerfassung im Ausland Informationen ähm gewinnen.
Ähm aber so insgesamt fühle er sich da jetzt nicht besonders angesprochen. Ähm.
Richter und Mobilfunk auf jeden Fall nicht und,
Er hätte auch nichts mit einem Austausch, mit Five Eyes äh starten zu tun, denn alles alle Informationen, die dort irgendwie gesammelt, erfasst werden, gebe man.
Bearbeitet an die BND-Zentrale in Pullach weiter und,
ähm mit den Five Eyes starten, also würde man nicht direkt zusammenarbeiten. Also er hat mit allem, er macht da, er weiß da überhaupt nicht, warum er da ist. War aber, glaube ich, auch schon zum zweiten Mal da und ähm scheint äh nach wie vor,
unklar sich darüber zu sein warum sich überhaupt irgendjemand für ihn interessiert. Zu kabeln hat er ähm.
Irgendwie nichts gesagt, also zu ob man jetzt Kabel erfasst, Lichtwellenleiter oder sonstiges.
Kurz wählen, auch welche andere Wellen und Lichtwellen würden sie ja irgendwie erfassen. Aber es gab keine Aussage, was sie da konkret tun.
Genau und dann sagt er aber, also er könne auch nicht ausschließen, dass in Gablingen NSA NSA Selektoren eingesetzt würden. Ähm,
Aber kein Rohmaterial sei von seiner Stelle an die NSA geflossen. Weder Metadaten,
Äh und auch keine kein Rohmaterial an Meterdaten. Das weiß er.
Keine Ahnung, was er da sucht, kann noch nicht mal ausschließen. Also er kann, kann eigentlich noch nicht mal genau sagen, was er da abhört, kann
kann nicht sagen, äh woher genau die Selektoren hat, aber er weiß, mit wem er die Sachen teilt, nämlich mit Pollack. Ja, so erwartet man auch eigentlich den Angestellten einer Behörde, weiß von nix
und reicht alles nach oben weiter.
Alles nach Vorschrift.
Alles nach Vorschrift. Dann gab es noch einen zweiten Zeugen, das ist der JS, der beim BND.
Von zweitausendsechs bis zweitausendzehn das Referat T zwei D leitete,
welches für die Nachrichtenbearbeitung und teils für den Austausch mit Auswärtigen Diensten zuständig war.
Zwei D.
Ähm.
Det? Zwei.
Die sind ja nummeriert, ich habe gehe nicht davon aus, dass das eine spezielle Abkürzung ist.
Okay.
Und ähm.
Er sagte, ja, wir haben niemals Rohmaterial an die oder ich habe niemals Rohmaterial an die NSA gegeben. Ähm.
Also Entschuldigung, das war ja der Zeile. Ähm verrutscht, genau, er hätte auch nix gemacht, hat damit nix zu tun und ähm.
Es habe aber quasi, also er hat kein Rohmaterial weitergegeben, aber es habe einen Austausch mit einigen Diensten der Five Eisstaaten gegeben und da gab es spezielle Arbeitsplätze.
Wo sie eine bilaterale, also von beiden Seiten die Möglichkeit hatten, über ein getrenntes System speziell zu einem Zielgebiet Informationen einzustellen,
Und dann habe es einen Überleitungspunkt am der NSA in Wiesbaden gegeben.
Dorthin hätten die Nachrichtenbearbeiter Informationen aber nicht automatisch,
in einem allgemeinen Push-Pull-Verfahren, sondern aktiv weitergegeben, ja? Also er sagt, wir haben aufgearbeitete, konkrete Informationen in dieses System eingepflegt und nicht irgendwie,
Selektor rein Ergebnis raus.
Ja, da haben sie wahrscheinlich dann.
Darstellung von JS.
Amis gesagt wurde so die waren das doch oder? Habe ich gehört.
Ja, ach ja, da.
Gut, also alles äh alles super in Ordnung.
Na ja, ich finde das schon ähm.
Enorm, wie, wieder offenbar die ganze Zeit am laufenden Band sich diese NSA-Ausschuss ja, die NSA-Untersuchungsausschussmitglieder da irgendwie äh verarschen äh lassen müssen, ne.
Ja, schauen wir mal, ob's ob wir demnächst auch noch ein BND U A dazu bekommen.
Könnte mir ja vorstellen, dass das dass die Drohung zieht und dass äh dass sie da bei den Selektoren nochmal versuchen, zwei, drei weitere Kompromisse zu machen. Oskar wird bestimmt noch eine Weile so weitergehen.
Jo, so ist es.
Sind wir eigentlich schon am Ende. Gibt noch einen kleinen Spendenaufruf, wa?
Gibt ein Spendenaufruf. Ja, das ist ein Thema, was wir immer mal wieder hatten. Das Tor Projekt, also ne, wir erinnern uns, dass anonymisierungsnetz Tor, wir haben erst letzte Woche darüber gesprochen.
Dass es da äh wiederholt Angriffe des FBI drauf gab, aber eben auch das Netz, dass es gemütlich gemacht hat, dass ein AdWords Norden über dieses vollüberwachte Netz noch überhaupt mit Journalisten kommunizieren konnte.
Und ähm ein Netz, das für viele,
Plattform heutzutage unerlässlich ist, Securedrop, Global Leaks, ähm ein Netz, das
insbesondere zensierten Regionen der Welt besonders wichtig ist, weil es erstmal so gut wie jede Zensurmaßnahme einfach schön säuberlich wieder umgehen kann,
ähm also ein eine Technik, die wir,
Für unsere Gesellschaft hin, in der heutigen Zeit brauchen. Und äh dieses Netz wird immer wieder äh.
Kritisch angemerkt, ist hauptsächlich finanziert durch ähm Gelder der US-Regierung, zwar zu achtzig bis neunzig Prozent,
Ähm das kommt aus verschiedenen Töpfen. Wie gesagt, es gibt ähm immer wieder diesen,
Konflikt zwischen Innenministerium und Außenministerium, Hillary Clinton hat als Außenministerin durchaus,
Tor gefördert, weil sie das als eine wichtiges, als ein wichtiges Tool für Diszidenten in anderen Ländern äh gesehen hat und denen,
Zensurfreiheit und sichere Kommunikation und Anonymität zur Verfügung stellen wollte, Kraft ihrer Möglichkeiten während wie gesagt,
dem Innenministerium unterstellte Einheiten wie äh FBI oder so durchaus auch Angriffe auf Tor.
Ausüben. Insofern ist es nicht ein ist es kein allgemeiner Grund dem Torprojekt,
Grundsätzlich misstrauisch gegenüber zu stehen, nur weil es größtenteils von der US-Regierung finanziert ist, denn es ist ja eine Open-Source-Projekt, an dem auch viele andere mitarbeiten. Aber es gibt ein äh Tor Kernentwicklerteam.
Und dieses äh speist sich aus,
Geldern, die das Torprojekt eintreibt und diese Gelder stammen zu signifikanten Teilen von Institutionen der US-Regierung. Jetzt zum Beispiel auch sowas äh den sogenannten,
ähm der.
Letztendlich auch äh an in einer langen Kette dann eben dem State Departement untersteht. Der speist sich aus dem Topf von
Das wiederum äh im Prinzip US Propaganda nach ähm in in nach Asien bringen soll und
irgendwo in unterhält Radio Free Ager dann auch diesen äh,
Diesen Open Tac fand und der hat dann halt ein paar Millionen äh im Jahr zu verteilen. Und da können Projekte sich bewerben.
Habe ich übrigens auch schon mal mit zwei Projekten gemacht und äh war daorts äh,
dann habe dann auch die oder das Team, in dem ich gearbeitet habe, hat die Förderung auch bekommen. Und äh,
Jetzt sagen die Torleute aber OK, schön und gut, denn es gibt kein grundsätzliches, technisches Problem an unserem
Projekt, was wir hier durchführen, dadurch, dass es von der US-Regierung gefandet ist, aber wenn wir irgendwann mal in Ungnade fallen, dann ist dieses Projekt vom einen auf den anderen Tag tot. Und es ist immer schlecht,
Wenn du äh in deinem für ein Projekt, das ja hier der Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung steht und kein äh Geschäftsmodell hat und auch
erstmal keins haben wird. Wenn du da auf die Großzügigkeit eines einzelnen Geldgebers äh,
so stark angewiesen bist. Deswegen haben sie jetzt eine,
Crowdfunding Kampagne gestartet und bitten also um einmalige oder monatliche Spenden, um das äh Torprojekt.
Am Leben zu halten. Da kann man also irgendwie hier so zwischen zehnhundert
zweihundertsechsundfünfzig, dreiundzwanzig und fünfhundert Dollar stehen zur Auswahl, man kann aber auch noch einen anderen Betrag sicher einfallen lassen, zum Beispiel zweiundvierzig und dann kann man Häkchen machen bei OneTimeto Nation oder und dann kann man,
kann man dort zu einem Spender für Thor werden. Man kann natürlich auch über Bitcoin und sonstige Wege dorthin spenden, ist natürlich klar, dass die Entwickler von vom Torprojekt da,
ähm sich über viele Möglichkeiten Gedanken gemacht haben. Und ich denke, das ist eine eine ganz gute Sache.
Und äh ich denke insbesondere ist wichtig jetzt äh daran zu denken, es kommt nicht darauf an, einen großen Betrag einmalig zu spenden, sondern es ist immer besser,
eine große Betrag regelmäßig zu spenden.
Das gilt auch für die Mütterebene.
Ja, zwei Anmerkungen äh dazu auch jetzt grad noch mal zu dieser,
teilweise äh kritisch geführten äh Debatte um darf man von äh von der von der Regierung nehmen, ist das sozusagen generell verwerflich,
Ist, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle klar machen muss, ist, dass diese gern unterstellte,
diese monolithische Struktur, die eine Regierung hat, ja, oder sagen wir mal,
Wir reden ja hier mehr von einem Staatsapparat und gar nicht mal nur von einer Regierung, also selbst wenn es eine Regierung gibt, äh gibt's auch da nochmal verschiedenste Kammern, also speziell in den USA, regionale Einflüsse und natürlich auch,
sagen wir mal, die,
doch relativ konstante personelle Besetzung eines Ministeriums. Das ist ja auch in Deutschland nicht anders. Also nur wenn die hier in eine andere Regierung kommt, dann ändert sich ja der Mindset eines Ministeriums nicht von heute auf morgen.
Und wenn da äh so ein Apparat einmal äh eine eine bestimmte Linie verfolgt, dann ist ja auch nicht so ohne Weiteres davon abzubringen.
Das kann äh im positiven wie im Negativen sein, aber das zeigt eben auch diese Unterstützung von Thor. Ja, also es wird natürlich gerne so gesehen mit ja, dann damit haben sie dann sozusagen die Kontrolle et cetera
Nee, es ist schon so, wie du auch eingangs gesagt hast. Es gibt da einfach auch verschiedene Strömungen. Es gibt sehr wohl in diesem amerikanischen Regierungs- und Beamtenbehörden,
Government-Apparat einfach auch Leute, die das eben ganz anders sehen und die da einfach ganz andere Wertvorstellungen haben und die sind natürlich auch in einem ewigen Kampf,
Falken. Nichtsdestotrotz droht natürlich jetzt und das ist glaube ich gerade auch so das Schreckgespenst, was äh weiß nicht, inwiefern das jetzt,
das ausgelöst hat, aber das steht ja natürlich auf jeden Fall im Raum, ja, dass also sehr wohl sein könnte, dass ähm im nächsten Jahr wirklich Vollidioten diese Regierung übernehmen.
Nee, um ich habe da die diese Diskussion wurden schon seit längerem geführt. Ähm dass das grundsätzlich nicht gut ist,
aber es ist nicht, wenn ich das ganz kurz sagen darf, es ist auch nicht so, dass diese dass die,
Entscheidungen für Tor. Jetzt wirklich irgendwie besonders weit oben in der Regierung stattfinden, ne? Da sitzt jetzt nicht Hillary Clinton mit einem Sack Geld und sagt, äh hier dreieinhalb Millionen für Tor oder sowas, ne? Sondern
ähm da unterhalten sich Regierungsinstitutionen
unterschiedliche Projektgruppen, Fans und so weiter, die verteilen in allen möglichen Bereichen Geld und es steht jetzt nirgendwo in Frage, dass der irgendwie
auf Gehalts der äh der Regierung,
Tor nicht mehr fördern würde. Was eher passieren würde ist, dass der Open Tack fand plötzlich immer kleiner wird, ja? Also ähm so laufen so laufen die Dinge dann eher nur um das nochmal, also,
so darzustellen. Es gibt auch keine konkrete Bedrohungslage. Das Tor jetzt sagt, oh nein, wir müssen, wir, wir müssen damit rechnen.
Ähm nicht mehr in der Zukunft finanziert zu werden, aber es gibt einfach,
Grundsätzlichen Anspruch zu sagen, es ist auch ohne, dass es eine akute Bedrohungslage gibt,
nicht klug, sich auf nur einen auf einen Geldgeber in dieser Form einzulassen. Ja, da kann immer mal was passieren,
und es ist grundsätzlich einfach besser, ein zu haben, denn ähm.
Man will ja auch eben in der in der Zukunft, in der Zukunft arbeiten. Da kann immer mal was passieren, da müssen nicht
müsste nicht direkt ähm Politiker durchdrehen, auch wenn das in den USA durchaus eine valide Sorge ist, dass irgendein Politiker durchdreht, ist ist jetzt nicht, dass das da besonders selten passieren würde.
Aber wie gesagt, wir wir hatten oder habe ich das schon gesagt oder noch nicht? Wir hatten einen Vortrag beim äh CCC Camp äh,
von dazu äh mit dem Titel Engoverments, weil das ist natürlich die andere Seite, wenn du das Geld nicht von Regierungen bekommst,
dann bekommst du es von äh Firmen und da kannst du,
teilweise argumentieren, dass die Regierung weniger Eigeninteresse verfolgen mit dem Funding
oder Eigennutzinteresse verfolgen mit dem Funding als äh Firmen, ja? Wunderschön ist es aber natürlich, wenn du dich einfach auf einen riesiges Bett,
von regelmäßig eintrudelnden kleineren und mittleren Beträgen bettest ähm und so wirklich ein belastbares,
Funding, für dein, für dein Projekt hast.
Ende der Sendung bringt.
Ja. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob wenn ich diese, wir haben das jetzt dieses äh BGH-Urteil ähm ich bin ja mal sehr gespannt.
Also diese dieser diese To-do-Liste, ne, die das BGH da gegeben hat und sagt, na ja äh,
Du musst aber erst einmal dich bei dem gemeldet haben, einmal bei dem gemeldet haben und und eine beauftragt haben, ne. Das kriege ich ja diese To-do-Liste kriege ich ja auch im Zweifelsfall an einem Tag abgehakt.
Ja? Also äh,
Diese Hürde ist mitunter gar nicht so groß. Vor allem, wenn du dir überlegst, dass es im im in diesem Internet ja noch ganz viele andere Länder gibt.
Und äh die alle irgendwie haben, die eventuell auf dich nicht reagieren. Das heißt, dass äh wenn das wenn das rund geht, hast du hier bald im im Schnellverfahren paar hundert Seiten pro Tag äh weggesperrt.
Ähnlich wie man's ja auch in anderen Ländern sieht, ne. Also wir erinnern uns an die Sperrung der CCC Seite in Großbritannien bei einigen Providern, nicht bei allen, ja, auch da wieder ähm.
Eine sehr, eine sehr, da sehen wir ja schon die Blüten, die die solche Sachen treiben. Also es ist ein.
Ja, es ist auch natürlich aus anderen Gründen auch generell abzulehnen, weil es bedeutet ja auch,
Das jetzt diese Infrastrukturen überhaupt erstmal geschaffen werden müssen, um so äh Anweisungen dann auch umzusetzen und das ist das eigentliche Problem, wenn wir wissen
dass dadurch einfach auch ein Missbrauchspotential äh entsteht, weil natürlich diese Listen, was gesperrt ist, jetzt auch wiederum nicht öffentlich sind, ne? Wer kontrolliert die Daten? Das ist auch, glaube ich, in diesem Urteil jetzt auch, also müssen dieser Pressemitteilung so noch nicht
also wir hatten ja früher dann so den Vorschlag von der Leyen mit na ja hier das kann auch dann die Polizei äh machen et cetera, also,
wer.
Pflegt diese Listen, wer wer bestimmt das, wer gibt es aus, wo wo ist sozusagen die zentrale Datenbank, in der alles, was zu sperren ist, vorgehalten wird, wer überprüft das, dass das auch
getan wird, in welchem Umfang das getan wird, auf welche Art und Weise das getan wird. Also es ist unklar.
Ja
In den nächsten Woche.
In der nächsten Woche haben wir bestimmt mal gute Neuigkeiten.
Bin ich mir auch sicher. Alles wird gut.
Logbuch Netzpolitik ist jetzt ein Telekommunikationsdienst.
Stimmt, ne, aber ich meine, wir nehmen hier Nachrichten und leiten sie weiter an Leute.
Die die ähm wir hatten, glaube ich, letzte Woche schon gesagt, dass es äh Ticket, dass der Ticketvorverkauf zum Kongress läuft.
Hatten wir.
Nicht sagen, weil das jetzt nochmal. Ich will nachher kein Gequengel hören, kaufe die Tickets jetzt. Nicht erst, wenn sie ausverkauft sind.
Ja. Genau mach das einfach. Ja und dann sehen wir uns da auch.
Ja, wir sehen uns da auch. Wir machen auch ein Logbuch, habe ich gehört. Steht in meinem Kalender. Ja. Ja.
Ja? Ja. Meinem auch.
Boah, Apple wieder.
Wir wissen alles.
Die wissen alles.
Quatsch. Die schreiben uns die Kalender.
So, wir danken an dieser Stelle oder ich danke an dieser Stelle noch dem äh Frank und äh wünsche einen angenehmen Restaufenthalt im Internet.
Genau und ich äh bedanke mich auch auf diesem Kanal nochmal für zehn Jahre Hörertreue, weil ich jetzt irgendwie die Mieterebene jetzt hier zehn Jahre durchgefeiert habe. Na ja.
Endlich doch noch dahin, die ganze Zeit denke ich, wann sagt das denn endlich? Meine Güte, zehn Jahre Meterebene.
Lastings, Last. Ja. Wann mache ich den Kram jetzt schon?
Bier schon auch vier Jahre irgendwie, ist schon richtig, schon richtig mein Hobby hier. Ja.
Ach ja. Wie war, wie ist es denn zehn Jahre? Bist du jetzt der Deutschlands Dienstälteste Podcaster eigentlich? Ja, ne? Ne, wer ist Philipp Hanse, Dienstältester oder.
Ja, also ähm äh gibt's ein paar äh Anegroben. Also von denen, die jetzt wirklich auch noch senden, Küchenradio hat, glaube ich, im Januar, Februar zweitausendfünf angefangen.
Und die Annika weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht genau, auch in dem Bereich. Ähm.
Ich hab's,
Dreiviertel Jahr vor mir hergeschoben und äh dann exekutiert, als es äh sozusagen nicht mehr aufzuhalten war zum zehnjährigen,
Geburtstag von Chaos Radio. Da habe ich das dann sozusagen offiziell alles als Podcast und dann halt Cast Radio Express mitgeliefert, quasi damit man eben auch was hat, was sozusagen nur vom Netz ist. Das war ja sozusagen,
Das eine war halt Chaosradio überhaupt mal per Podcasting verfügbar zu machen, obwohl's ja eigentlich eine normale Radiosendung war. Ne, das sogenannte Postcasting und dann,
eben auch so ein Format, was irgendwie äh äh aus dem Netz entsteht und ja, dann in der Folge auch seinen,
eigenen Weg gefunden hat. Ähm ja, ich kann da nur an einen längeren Text verweisen, den ich auf Meterebene im E geschrieben habe,
wo ich da auch diese ganze Gedankenwelt, die mich da äh am Anfang und zwischendurch und am Ende begleitet hat,
nochmal zusammengefasst habe, das könnt ihr euch mal durchlesen und dann könnt ihr auch mal den Meter ebene Podcast gleich noch mit dazu abonnieren, was so ein kleiner Kanal ist, der,
Immer wenn's mal was Wichtiges zu erzählen gibt äh in Audio auch noch was erzählt,
ins neue Podcast gibt oder irgendwas ausgesetzt oder wieder neu eingesetzt wird,
Ja, das war's jetzt aber wirklich. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Jo. Bis dann. Ciao, ciao. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.